I don't like birds,
I don't like birds.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Macayla Woodley.
I'm a part of a
big team that train
animals for "Animal Control."
This is full
time, so it's busy.
I'm usually making sure
that every wild animal
that we're having on
the show is comfortable.
But every animal has
its own different kink
that you kind of have to
work out and work around.
And you are just
as cute and adorable.
Bunnies are very
challenging because they only
care about food.
And they are a prey animal,
so everything is scary to them
at first.
So you have to work them
through that before you
can even start training them.
[YELLS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The ferret we
had with Michael.
Bad choice.
It was a scene that we had
to put the ferret on his chest.
He was kind of supposed to
pretend to, like, freak out.
[SCREAMS] [LAUGH]
Just that was fun to watch.
I worked with
a young kangaroo.
I think it was-- he
was a first time actor.
And honestly, it showed.
[GROANS]
It's on me, now.
They wanted to have
python rehearsal,
which is also the name of a
new movie I have coming out.
Does this look like it
would have gotten this way?
Joel's great with the animals.
You got that, kitty cat?
Actually, everyone on
this show has been good.
And sometimes, that
can be hard with actors
because some of them aren't
as willing to do those things.
Grace was hesitant
about the iguana.
That was the most terrifying.
I didn't think I had
a problem with them
until I saw it up close.
I'm pretty sure there's
footage of me freaking out.
He doesn't like me.
Oh, my god. (WHIMPERING)
I'm not doing good at all.
It ended up being
a really great day,
and she warmed up quite quickly.
[SULTRY MUSIC]
There's never a dull moment.
It's been the most
amazing experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MOOS]
[MUSIC CONTINUES]